an alarm goes off in the drills
simulator the crew tries to find out
what's wrong
is there a breach in the borehole
everything is got to be checked the
Palmer speedo in sport align we're going
to flush the borehole to find out
whether we've got a problem
this is europe's only school for master
drillers it's located in the German city
of Silla
which is a big center for Germany's oil
and gas industry the first oil rigs were
set up here in the 19th century they
started tearing them down about 50 years
ago all that's left now is the supply
sector which includes about 40
businesses for example heartburn valves
and well heads it specializes in
drilling technology all the parts the
company makes are rigorously tested they
have to withstand a lot of heat pressure
and weight up to 3,000 meters of
conveyor pipe are connected to a single
wellhead this is part of the wellhead
it's where the conveyor strands start we
hang about a hundred and fifty to two
hundred tons off of this element a truck
weighs about 20 tons so we have to be
able to hang about 10 trucks from it
Harper did about 25 million euros in
turnover in 2015 that's a lot less than
just a few years ago one reason why is
that the Russian market has been hit
hard by a weak ruble which makes German
imports more expensive in fact a trade
representative is here today to discuss
the situation the Russians need this
equipment
in some cases you cannot do with without
such products on very severe conditions
like heart and producers so that's why
all the same we have to turn to Hartman
we I'm saying Russia not not mud myself
personally so that's why we are trying
to find a new ways to bring the price
down a weak ruble and international
sanctions imposed on Russia are regional
problems not so the global crash in oil
prices nobody at Hartman has lost their
job yet but that could soon change many
production facilities just aren't
profitable anymore my problem is that no
one knows where oil prices are going to
go now will they continue to fall some
8,000 jobs in celle depend on the oil
and gas industry some businesses in this
sector have cut jobs including the
German subsidiaries of US corporations
like Halliburton we are not allowed to
film here but a member of the works
council comes out to talk to us they cut
92 jobs 40% of the workforce we used to
have 232 workers there are talks of a
possible merger to cut costs
Halliburton wants to take over a
competitor Baker Hughes it's not clear
how that merger would affect workers
here
back at the school for master drillers
the candidates have come here for
specialized training most already have
many years of drilling experience in the
oil industry they're also feeling the
effects of the drop in oil prices we
used to have long term contracts ten
years or if you were lucky five years
with an option for five more but those
days are gone thanks to the situation in
this sector and to the drop in oil
prices so it's just a matter of luck
whether you get a longer term contract
or have to scramble from job to job
films they still go from one of two bowl
of hummus a lot of deep drilling
projects are now on hold they'll only be
profitable if oil prices rise again